Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. This episode contains descriptions of violence against the family, including children. It won't be suitable for all listeners. Japan's capital city of Tokyo is made up of 23 special wards, each of which is a self-governing municipality with several districts.
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序上或我们网站上的本集节目说明。本集包含对针对家庭（包括儿童）暴力的描述。它并不适合所有听众。日本的首都东京由23个特别区组成，每个区都是一个自治市，下辖若干个街区。
Built on the western side of Tokyo, the Setagaya Ward is the second-largest and most densely populated. It is a residential, leafy area, with a reputation for being family-friendly while offering easy access to the city. The four-member Miyazawa family lived in a semi-detached, three-story house in Setagaya's Kami-Soshigaya district. Two hundred similar homes were originally built in the area, but when the Miyazawa's moved in in 1990, most of these had been demolished to make way for Soshigaya Park, a public recreational
世田谷区位于东京西部，是第二大且人口最稠密的区。这是一个绿树成荫的住宅区，以家庭友好著称，同时又能轻松通往市区。宫泽一家的四口人住在世田谷区上祖师谷的一栋半独立式三层住宅里。该地区最初建有两百栋类似的房屋，但当宫泽一家于1990年搬进来时，其中大部分已被拆除，为祖师谷公园让路，这是一个公共娱乐
space consisting of play areas, tennis courts, and grassy lawns. By the year 2000, the Miyazawa's property was one of only four remaining houses that were essentially located inside the parklands. Soshigaya Park was situated along the east and south side of the house, with the Senkawa River to the west. Directly behind and separated only by a fence was a skate park and playground. The area was typically quiet and safe, but the addition of the skate park had introduced a hive of activity and lots of noise.
空间，由游乐区、网球场和草坪组成。到2000年，宫泽家的房产是仅存的四栋实际上位于公园内的房屋之一。祖师谷公园位于房屋的东侧和南侧，西侧则是仙川河流。直接在房屋后方且仅隔一道栅栏的是一个滑板公园和游乐场。该地区通常安静而安全，但滑板公园的加入带来了一个活动中心和大量的噪音。
There were also sightings of suspicious individuals in the area, which led to some safety concerns for the Miyazawa family. The Kami-Soshigaya district had once been overseen by a neighborhood watch program, but with so few houses remaining, security had become an issue. As the government was offering a buyback scheme to allow for further expansion of the parklands, the Miyazawa's had decided to take advantage of the offer and applied to be relocated. The family was made up of parents, Mikio and Yasuko, and their two young children, daughter Nina and son Rei.
该地区还出现了可疑人员的踪迹，这引发了宫泽一家对安全的担忧。上祖师谷地区曾由一个社区巡逻计划监督，但由于剩下的房屋寥寥无几，安保已成了一个问题。由于政府提供了一项回购计划以便进一步扩建公园绿地，宫泽一家决定利用这一优惠，申请搬迁。这个家庭由父母干男和泰子，以及他们的两个幼小孩子——女儿妮娜和儿子礼组成。
Mikio and Yasuko had met at a self-development seminar during the 1980s, eventually going on to marry in December of 1986. 44-year-old Mikio was a creative man with a love for animation. His childhood was spent participating in puppetry and other theatrical productions at school. After graduating from university, he worked as an animator and question developer for quiz programs. He eventually secured a position at Interbrand, a London-based marketing company with over 20 officers worldwide.
干男和泰子在20世纪80年代的一次自我发展研讨会上相遇，并最终于1986年12月结婚。44岁的干男是一个热爱动画的富有创造力的人。他的童年是在学校参与木偶戏和其他戏剧制作中度过的。大学毕业后，他做过动画师和问答节目的问题开发人员。他最终在Interbrand获得了一个职位，该公司是一家总部位于伦敦的营销公司，在世界各地拥有20多家办事处。
Both clients included high-profile brands such as Nissan, Microsoft and Xerox. Mikio worked in their Tokyo branch, developing corporate identity for major corporations. His colleagues described him as a congenial man who got on well with everyone. 41-year-old Yasuko was a kind, patient and intelligent woman who ran what was known as a cram school from the family's home. Called a juku in Japanese, a cram school is a private school that offers supplementary classes for students wanting extra help preparing for key academic admission exams. The Miyazawa's plans to move were complicated by the fact that their six-year-old son, Rei,
两家客户都包括诸如日产、微软和施乐等知名品牌。干男在他们的东京分公司工作，为各大企业开发企业形象。他的同事形容他是一个随和的人，与所有人都相处得很好。41岁的泰子是一位善良、耐心且聪明的女性，她在家里经营着一所被称为补习班的学校。日语中称之为“juku”，补习班是一所私立学校，为希望在准备关键学术入学考试时获得额外帮助的学生提供补充课程。宫泽一家的搬迁计划因他们六岁的儿子礼而变得复杂，
had learning disabilities and a speech impediment that required special attention. Rei attended a public kindergarten in Setagaya, but his parents were seeking professional help before enrolling him in primary school as they wanted to give him the best possible start in life. His sister, eight-year-old Nina, was a bright, intelligent girl who had skipped a grade at school. She was very active with a passion for soccer, piano and ballet and would show off her dance moves to her extended family.
他有学习障碍和语言障碍，需要特别关注。礼在世田谷的一家公立幼儿园上学，但在他升入小学之前，他的父母一直在寻求专业帮助，因为他们想给他人生中最好的开端。他的姐姐，八岁的妮娜，是一个聪明伶俐的女孩，在学校跳级过。她非常活跃，对足球、钢琴和芭蕾充满热情，并会在大家庭成员面前展示她的舞步。
Both Mikio and Yasuko adored their children and kept a record of their physical growth by periodically marking their heights on their living room wall. Given the unique situation that the Miyazawa family faced, the government gave them permission to remain in their kami-soshigaya property until they found a location suited to Rei's needs. In late 2000, the Miyazawa's found a suitable plot of land to build their new home on, with the intention that Yasuko's mother, Haruko, sister Anne, and Anne's husband, Hiroyuki, would join them as neighbors.
干男和泰子都非常疼爱他们的孩子，并通过定期在客厅墙上标记身高来记录他们的身体生长情况。鉴于宫泽一家面临的独特情况，政府特许他们留在上祖师谷的房产中，直到他们找到适合礼的需求的地点。2000年底，宫泽一家找到了一块适合建造新房的土地，并打算让泰子的母亲春子、妹妹安妮以及安妮的丈夫弘幸作为邻居加入他们。
The three currently lived next door to the Miyazawa's on the other side of their semi-detached home in Kami-soshigaya, and they were eager to stay together. They were all due to move out in March of 2001, meaning they only had to put up with the rowdy crowds at the skate park for a few more months. On the morning of Sunday, December 31, Haruko tried to phone her daughter, as she did most mornings, but the call wouldn't go through. By 10am, Haruko still hadn't seen or heard from Yasuko or the rest of the family, and she began to worry.
这三个人目前住在上祖师谷宫泽家半独立式住宅的另一侧隔壁，他们渴望住在一起。他们本应在2001年3月搬走，这意味着他们只需要再忍受滑板公园里吵闹的人群几个月。12月31日星期日早上，春子像往常一样试图给女儿打电话，但电话打不通。到了上午10点，春子依然没有看到或听到泰子或家里其他人的消息，她开始担心起来。
There was no internal connection between the two homes, so she went outside and knocked on the Miyazawa's front door. When there was no response, she let herself inside. The Miyazawa's house was split across three stories. The entrance opened to a reception room, which Mikio Miyazawa used as a study. Once the rear of the room was a short flight of stairs that led to the mezzanine level, which hosted Rei and Nina's shared bedroom, a small bathroom, and a separate toilet. A further flight of stairs led to the second floor, where the kitchen, living room, and
两栋房子之间没有内部通道，于是她走到外面，敲了敲宫泽家的前门。见无人回应，她便自己推门进去了。宫泽家的房子分为三层。入口通向一个会客室，干男·宫泽将其用作书房。房间后部有一段短楼梯，通往夹层，那里有礼和妮娜共用的卧室、一个小浴室和一个独立的厕所。再上一段楼梯通往二楼，厨房、客厅和
laundry were located. On the mezzanine level, a pull-down ladder granted access to the third floor attic, which contained Mikio and Yasuko's bedroom. At the base of the ground floor stairs, Haruko discovered the blood-soaked body of her son-in-law, Mikio. She continued upstairs to the mezzanine level, where, on the landing, she found the bodies of her daughter Yasuko and granddaughter Nina. They too were lying in pools of blood.
洗衣房都在那里。在夹层，一个可拉下的梯子可以通往三楼的阁楼，里面有干男和泰子的卧室。在一楼楼梯底部，春子发现了她的女婿干男那血迹斑斑的尸体。她继续上楼来到夹层，在平台上，她发现了她的女儿泰子和孙女妮娜的尸体。她们也躺在血泊中。
Haruko touched them to check if they were still alive, but both were cold. In a state of shock, she rushed out of the house and called the police. Attending officers found the body of Rei Miyazawa in the bunk bed he shared with his sister. Investigators pieced together a probable series of events based on the presentation of the crime scene. It appeared as though the killer had climbed the fence at the rear of the property and scaled up to the mezzanine level. A screen that covered the bathroom window had been removed, indicating the killer had done
春子摸了摸她们，想看看她们是否还活着，但两人都已经冰凉。处于震惊状态中的她冲出屋子，报了警。赶到的警员在礼·宫泽与姐姐共用的双层床上发现了他的尸体。调查人员根据犯罪现场的呈现，拼凑出了一系列可能的事发经过。凶手似乎翻越了房产后方的栅栏，爬到了夹层。覆盖浴室窗户的纱窗被拆除了，这表明凶手是这样做的
this to enter the house. After strangling six-year-old Rei in his bedroom, the killer then came across Nina and launched an attack. As Mikio was the only member of the household not dressed for bed, it was believed he was working in his study when he heard the disturbance and went upstairs to investigate. He then came face-to-face with the intruder, who brandished a 34-centimeter long knife with a 21-centimeter blade that was typically used for preparing sashimi, a Japanese delicacy of raw fish and meat.
进入房子的。在卧室里勒死六岁的礼之后，凶手接着遇到了妮娜并发起了袭击。由于干男是家里唯一一个没有换上睡衣的成员，人们认为他当时正在书房工作，听到动静后上楼查看。接着，他与闯入者正面遭遇，对方挥舞着一把34厘米长、刀刃长21厘米的刀，这通常用于制作刺身——一种日本生鱼和生肉的美食。
Mikio was stabbed upwards of ten times and either fell or was pushed down the stairs. A piece of the killer's blade was lodged in one of Mikio's wounds, having broken off during the frenzied attack. Meanwhile, Nina had climbed the ladder to her parents' bedroom to alert her mother. An open first aid kit was found in the bedroom, along with bloodstained bandages on one of the futon beds. Nina's blood was found on some of the items. It was believed the eight-year-old had sustained injuries in her initial confrontation with
干男被刺了十多刀，随后跌落或被推下了楼梯。凶手刀刃的一小块断在了干男的伤口里，是在狂暴的袭击中折断的。与此同时，妮娜爬梯子到了父母的卧室向母亲求救。卧室里有一个打开的急救箱，其中一张榻榻米床上还放着沾血的绷带。在一些物品上发现了妮娜的血迹。人们认为，这名八岁女孩在与持刀入侵者的最初对峙中受了伤，
the armed intruder, which Yasuko had tended to. The pair then ventured down to the mezzanine level, perhaps anticipating that the perpetrator had left. However, the killer was still inside the house and had replaced his broken knife with a larger one from the kitchen. The violence inflicted on Yasuko and Nina was described by investigators as overkill. News of the quadruple homicide left the Miyazawa's friends and relatives horrified, with Mikio's mother passing out from shock when she was informed.
泰子曾为她包扎过。随后，两人冒险下到夹层，或许是预料到凶手已经离开。然而，凶手仍在屋里，并用厨房里更大的一把刀替换了他断掉的刀。调查人员将对泰子和妮娜施加的暴力描述为过度杀戮。四人谋杀案的消息让宫泽的朋友和亲戚感到惊恐万状，干男的母亲在得知消息后震惊得昏厥过去。
Police Chief Takeshi Sucida later said, When I think about the brutality, I just wonder how could a sane person carry out such an extreme crime? He slashed them from above the chest to the face as if he tormented them. It was extremely brutal, and to the way he finished them off in the very end. It was so horrific, we couldn't show those guards to the devastated victims' families. There are no other cases in which the victims have been cut up like this. The Miyazawa's phone line had been disconnected and their house had been ransacked.
警察局长堤田武后来表示：“当我想到这种残忍行径时，我只是在想，一个理智的人怎么能犯下如此极端的罪行？他从胸部上方一直割到面孔，仿佛在折磨他们。这极其残忍，包括他在最后了结他们的方式。它是如此恐怖，以至于我们无法将那些照片展示给受害者心碎的家属。没有其他案件中受害者被这样肢解过。”宫泽家的电话线被切断了，他们的房子也被洗劫一空。
Personal documents such as diaries, identification cards, utility bills, receipts and bank statements were spread across the dining room table and the sofa on the second floor. In the bathtub, police found some of Mikio's work documents, receipts, Yasuko's cram school paperwork, sanitary items, towels, ice cream wrappers and the random contents of a drawer that had been emptied. Stolen from the home was a tuition fee paid by one of Yasuko's students, which amounted to approximately 200,000 yen, the equivalent of around 3,000 Australian dollars at the time.
日记、身份证件、公用事业账单、收据和银行对账单等个人文件散落在二楼的餐桌和沙发上。在浴缸里，警察发现了一些干男的工作文件、收据、泰子的补习班文件、卫生用品、毛巾、冰淇淋包装纸和一个被清空抽屉里的杂物。从家中被盗的是泰子的一名学生支付的学费，金额约为20万日元，相当于当时大约3000澳元。
Mikio and Yasuko's wallets were found empty, and based on the documents that had been spread out on the table, it appeared as though the killer had been trying to figure out the pin for Mikio's bank cards. The theory then arose that the crime was motivated by robbery. However, cash, passbooks, bank cards and jewellery had been left behind. Mikio's documents featured Kanji, one of three Japanese alphabets along with Hiragana and Katakana. Kanji is regarded as the most complex of the three.
干男和泰子的钱包被发现时空空如也，根据散落在桌子上的文件来看，凶手似乎一直在试图弄清楚干男银行卡的密码。于是产生了一种理论，即这起犯罪的动机是抢劫。然而，现金、存折、银行卡和珠宝却被留下了。干男的文件中含有汉字，这是与平假名和片假名一起的三个日本字母表之一。汉字被认为是这三者中最复杂的。
It is made up of more than 2,000 Chinese characters and is taught to students during the nine years of compulsory childhood education. As the killer had rifled and seemingly read through Mikio's paperwork, police believed he was able to read Kanji and was likely raised in Japan. A blood-stained raglan-style sweatshirt was found on the second floor. As it didn't contain any slash marks, it was presumed to have belonged to the killer. Other foreign clothing items and accessories were also found folded neatly at the scene, presumably by the killer.
它由2000多个汉字组成，在九年义务制儿童教育期间传授给学生。由于凶手曾翻阅并似乎阅读过干男的文件，警方认为他认得汉字，很可能是在日本长大的。二楼发现了一件沾血的插肩袖运动衫。由于上面没有任何刀割的痕迹，因此推测这件衣服属于凶手。现场还整齐地叠放着其他外国衣物和配饰，据推测也是凶手放的。
These included a grey hat, a black jacket, a green-checkered scarf, a grey and black hip bag, a pair of black gloves and two black handkerchiefs. Multiple footprints were also found throughout the property, including near the bunk bed in the children's room, on the stairs, and outside the house underneath the bathroom window. The footprints on the stairs switched position halfway up from the wall side to the handrail side, a unique stepping pattern consistent with military training. The footprints outside suggested that the killer used the bathroom window to exit the
其中包括一顶灰色帽子、一件黑色夹克、一条绿格围巾、一个灰黑色腰包、一副黑色手套和两块黑色手帕。整个房子里还发现了多处脚印，包括儿童房的双层床附近、楼梯上以及浴室窗户下方的屋外。楼梯上的脚印在半途中从靠墙一侧切换到了靠扶手一侧，这是一种与军事训练相符的独特步态模式。外面的脚印表明凶手是通过浴室窗户离开房子的，
house rather than enter it, as was initially thought. A large amount of foreign blood was found in the attic bedroom and throughout the rest of the house, including on discarded bandages, towels, and sanitary pads. Testing confirmed it wasn't from any of the victims, meaning it was the killers. The killer was a male with a blood type A. Toxicology results showed there were no drugs in his system and he was a non-smoker. A bandage covered in the killer's blood was found stuck to the back of a notebook in the living room, which led investigators to conclude that the killer must have injured his right
而不是像最初认为的那样从那里进入。在阁楼卧室和房子的其余部分发现了大量外国人的血液，包括在丢弃的绷带、毛巾和卫生巾上。经检测，这些血迹不属于任何受害者，这意味着它们属于凶手。凶手是一名A型血的男性。毒理学结果显示，他体内没有毒品，且不吸烟。在客厅的一个笔记本背面发现了一块沾满凶手血迹的绷带，这使调查人员推断凶手一定在某次袭击中弄伤了右手，
hand during one of the attacks and tended to his wounds with the family's first aid kit. As he then ransacked the house, one of the bandages likely peeled off and came to be stuck on the notebook. Due to the brutality of the crime, the abundant forensic evidence, and the level of destruction within the house, police initially suspected multiple perpetrators were involved. However, the footprints and unidentified blood had come from one person. There was also evidence that the killer had remained in the house for some time after
并用家里的急救箱处理了伤口。当他在随后洗劫房屋时，其中一块绷带很可能剥落并粘在了笔记本上。由于犯罪的残忍性、丰富的法医证据以及屋内的破坏程度，警方最初怀疑有多个作案者。然而，脚印和未识别的血液都来自同一个人。还有证据表明，凶手在谋杀发生后在房子里逗留了一段时间。
the murders. It appeared he had slept or rested on the living room's sofa and also consumed food and drinks belonging to the Miyazawa family, including melon, four bottles of barley tea, and four ice creams. One of the ice cream wrappers was found in the bathtub, another was in the living room, and two were beside the computer on the first floor. Furthermore, unflushed feces were found in one of the toilets. The victims were estimated to have been murdered at approximately 11.30pm on Saturday, December
他似乎在客厅的沙发上睡过觉或休息过，还食用了宫泽一家的食物和饮料，包括甜瓜、四瓶大麦茶和四个冰淇淋。其中一个冰淇淋包装纸在浴缸里被发现，另一个在客厅，两个在一楼电脑旁。此外，在一个马桶里发现了未冲洗的粪便。据估计，受害者于星期六12月30日晚上11点30分左右遇害。
30. According to Mikio's computer records, the killer had used the device to access the internet at 11.18am on Sunday, December 31. He had visited the websites of Mikio and Yasuko's employers, and also browsed the website of a theatrical group in Tokyo, attempting to use Mikio's bank card to book tickets for an upcoming show. Mikio's computer log also showed that it was used again at approximately 10am, moments before the bodies were discovered.
根据干男的电脑记录，凶手曾于12月31日星期日上午11点18分使用该设备上网。他访问了干男和泰子雇主的网站，还浏览了东京一个戏剧团体的网站，试图用干男的银行卡预订即将上演的演出门票。干男的电脑日志还显示，在大约上午10点尸体被发现前不久，该电脑被再次使用过。
It appeared the killer had remained in the house until then, near 10 hours after the murders, then fled when Haruko arrived on the scene. Haruko and her daughter, Anne Iriere, who lived next door, said the walls between the two homes had been soundproofed to enable both families to live side by side in peace. However, they did recall hearing a loud thud from the Miyazawa's house at approximately 11.30pm the night of the murders. To figure out what the noise could have been, police conducted a test where they pulled down the ladder that led to Mikio and Yasuko's attic bedroom.
凶手似乎一直留在屋里直到那时，即谋杀发生近10个小时后，然后在春子到达现场时逃跑。春子和住在隔壁的女儿安妮·入江表示，两栋房子之间的墙壁已经做过隔音处理，以使两家人能够和平地毗邻而居。然而，她们确实记得在谋杀当晚11点30分左右听到从宫泽家传出的一声巨响。为了弄清楚这声音可能是什么，警方进行了一项测试，他们拉下了通往干男和泰子阁楼卧室的梯子。
Haruko and Anne confirmed that this had been what they'd heard. Anne said she went to bed at around 1am, but didn't hear any other notable sounds. Japan was generally considered to be a safe country, but the burst of the real estate bubble during the early 1990s had prompted a major recession. This led to high unemployment rates, a decrease in asset value, soaring debt, large-scale illegal immigration, and a shift in traditional values. Recovery was slow, and Japan's once-low crime rate had steadily risen throughout the decade. In the year 2000, the crime rate increased by 12.5% compared to the previous year.
春子和安妮确认，这就是她们当时听到的声音。安妮说她在大约凌晨1点上床睡觉，但没有听到其他引人注目的声音。日本通常被认为是一个安全的国家，但在20世纪90年代初房地产泡沫破裂后引发了严重的经济衰退。这导致了高失业率、资产价值下降、债务飙升、大规模非法移民以及传统价值观的转变。复苏缓慢，日本曾经很低的犯罪率在这十年里稳步上升。在2000年，犯罪率比前一年上升了12.5%。
As described by The New York Times, the Japanese police had once had a globally revered reputation for their high morals, ethics, and devotion to duty. They were considered virtually incorruptible and highly efficient in solving crimes. However, in 2000, there had been a series of police scandals across the country involving corruption, negligence, drug abuse, extortion, bribery, hazing of fellow officers, coverups, and sexual assault. The Japanese police force faced heavy criticism that they were losing the fight against crime. As reported by The New York Times, a public opinion poll conducted in early 2000 revealed
正如《纽约时报》所描述的那样，日本警察曾因其高尚的道德、伦理和对职责的奉献精神而在全球享有崇高的声誉。他们被认为几乎是廉洁奉公的，并且在破案方面效率极高。然而，在2000年，全国各地发生了一系列警察丑闻，涉及腐败、失职、吸毒、勒索、受贿、欺负同僚、掩盖真相以及性侵犯。日本警察部队面临着他们正在输掉打击犯罪之战的严厉批评。正如《纽约时报》所报道的那样，2000年初进行的一项民意调查显示，
that 60% of Japanese citizens said their trust in police was declining, while 45% no longer trusted the police at all. The Miyazawa family murders elevated the public's growing concerns, and the pressure was on for police to make a quick arrest. In an unprecedented move that highlighted the shocking nature of the crime, Superintendent General of the Tokyo Metropolitan Police Department, Takeshi Noda, attended the Miyazawa crime scene in person, telling detectives, Investigators worked to piece together the family's last known movements using witness
60%的日本公民表示他们对警察的信任正在下降，而45%的人则完全不再信任警察。宫泽一家谋杀案加剧了公众日益增长的担忧，警方面临着迅速破案的压力。东京都警视厅总监野田健亲自出席了宫泽案犯罪现场，这一前所未有的举动突显了这起犯罪的令人震惊的性质，他对侦探们说：调查人员利用目击者证词和技术数据，拼凑出了该家庭生前的最后行踪。
statements and technological data. They determined that during the day of Saturday, December 30, the Miyazawa's went shopping in an arcade near Chitose Karasuyama Railway Station, approximately 1.6km north of their home. At around 6pm, they were seen at another shopping centre near Sayijo Gakuenmae Railway Station, 1.8km south of their home. The Miyazawa's arrived home just before 7pm. Yasuko used the home telephone to call her mother before the family ate dinner together.
他们确定，在12月30日星期六白天，宫泽一家前往位于他们家以北约1.6公里的千岁乌山火车站附近的一条商业街购物。傍晚6点左右，他们在距离家以南1.8公里的另一个购物中心被看到，该购物中心靠近成城学园前火车站。宫泽一家在晚上7点前不久回到家中。泰子用家里的电话给母亲打了电话，然后一家人一起吃了晚饭。
At 9.38pm, Nina's computer was used to watch a television show online, and at 10.45pm, Mikio logged onto his computer to read his work emails. This was the last recorded action of any family member, with the murders occurring shortly after. The family's friends and relatives were questioned in a bid to establish whether they had any known enemies, or had reported anything suspicious in the lead-up to their deaths. Mikio's colleagues told police that he hadn't been working on anything particularly sensitive or controversial, ruling out the possibility that the murders were connected to his work.
晚上9点38分，妮娜的电脑被用来在线观看电视节目，晚上10点45分，干男登录电脑查看工作邮件。这是任何家庭成员的最后一次有记录的行动，谋杀案随后不久发生。警方对该家庭的朋友和亲戚进行了讯问，以确定他们是否有任何已知的仇人，或者在他们遇害前夕是否报告过任何可疑情况。干男的同事告诉警方，他没有从事任何特别敏感或具争议性的工作，从而排除了谋杀与他的工作有关的可能性。
Mikio kept a detailed diary of his daily activities and expenses, and investigators found nothing within to suggest anything troubling was happening in his life. However, in the week leading up to the murders, Mikio had admonished a group of teenagers who were hanging out at the skate park behind their house, telling them off for being loud. And at the same time, he had also confronted a group of young members of the Boso Zoku motorcycle gang who were causing nuisance in the area. Boso Zoku members had a reputation for being violent and dangerous, and were known to carry weapons.
干男详细记录了他的日常活动和开支，调查人员在其中没有发现任何迹象表明他的生活中有任何令人烦恼的事情发生。然而，在谋杀发生前的一周里，干男曾训斥了一群在他们家房后滑板公园闲逛的青少年，斥责他们太吵。与此同时，他还与一群在当地制造麻烦的暴走族年轻成员发生了对峙。暴走族成员以暴力和危险著称，并且随身携带武器。
Five days before the murders, Yasuko had complained to her father that someone had been repeatedly parking outside her home, even though there were plenty of other parking spaces available in the area. Two days later, on December 27, a witness cited a middle-aged man walking around the perimeter of the Miyazawa's home, as though he was studying it. On December 29, a young man wearing clothes similar to those left behind by the killer was seen at Sayijo Gakuen Maya Railway Station, which was located next to one of the shopping centres that the Miyazawa's visited the following day.
在谋杀案发生前五天，泰子曾向父亲抱怨说，尽管该地区有很多其他停车位，但总是有人把车停在她家门外。两天后的12月27日，一名目击者看到一名中年男子在宫泽家四周徘徊，仿佛在观察它。12月29日，一名穿着与凶手遗留物品相似衣服的年轻男子在成城学园前火车站被看到，该火车站毗邻宫泽一家第二天造访的其中一个购物中心。
That same day, a sashimi knife matching the murder weapon was purchased at the shopping centre. This particular knife was one of 1500 manufactured in Japan's Fukui Prefecture in the year 2000. The next day, the day of the murders, the same young male suspect was seen at Sangawa Railway Station, just 1.5km from the Miyazawa's house. Locals reported that between June and December of 2000, stray cats around Soshigaya Park had been found mutilated, with their tails cut off or their skin stripped. This appeared to be a promising lead, but the person responsible for the animal abuse
同一天，一把与凶器相匹配的刺身刀在那个购物中心被购买。这把特定的刀是2000年在日本福井县制造的1500把刀中的一把。第二天，即谋杀案发生的当天，人们在距离宫泽家仅1.5公里的三川火车站看到了同一名年轻的男性嫌疑人。当地人报告说，在2000年6月至12月期间，祖师谷公园周围的流浪猫遭到残害，它们的尾巴被砍断或皮肤被剥离。这似乎是一条很有希望的线索，但虐待动物的肇事者
was later determined to be a bank clerk, who was ruled out in connection with the Miyazawa family murders. Investigators soon learned of three suspicious incidents that had occurred in the early morning hours of Sunday, December 31, shortly after the murders. Just after midnight, a taxi driver had picked up three men near Soshigaya Park and drove them to a nearby railway station. When the men left the cab, the taxi driver noticed several blood stains on the back seat, the biggest of which was approximately 19mm in diameter.
后来被查明是一名银行职员，他与宫泽一家谋杀案的联系被排除了。调查人员很快获悉了发生在12月31日星期日凌晨、谋杀案发生后不久的三起可疑事件。刚过午夜，一名出租车司机在祖师谷公园附近接了三名男子，并将他们载到附近的火车站。当这三名男子下车时，出租车司机注意到后座上有几个血迹，其中最大的直径约为19毫米。
Police tested the stains and determined they were chocolate. In a separate incident at dawn, a woman had been driving past Soshigaya Park when a man jumped in front of her car, lightly brushing it. She stopped and got out to check on the man and to notice the blood on the back of his left hand. Another suspicious incident had occurred at 5.25am on December 31. A man aged in his 30s walked into a medical office located at Tobu Niko Railway Station, approximately 120km north of the Miyazawa's house, seeking treatment for a knife wound
警察对这些血迹进行了测试，确定它们是巧克力。在黎明时分的另一起事件中，一名女子正驾车驶过祖师谷公园，突然有一个男子跳到她的车前，轻轻擦碰到了车身。她停下车，下车查看该男子的状况，并注意到了他左手背上的血迹。另一起可疑事件发生在12月31日上午5点25分。一名30多岁的男子走进位于距离宫泽家以北约120公里的东武日光火车站的一家诊所，要求治疗手上的刀伤，
on his hand that was so deep the bone was exposed. Medical staff treated the injury but didn't ask how it was sustained and the man left without leaving his name. As the investigation into the brutal murders continued, a funeral was held for all four members of the Miyazawa family. Niko's mother, Setsuko, was so traumatised that she was unable to walk and had to be carried inside. Yasuko's mother and sister had become so afraid of the house they shared with the slain
伤口深得连骨头都露出来了。医务人员对伤口进行了处理，但没有询问伤势是如何造成的，该男子没有留下姓名便离开了。随着对这起残忍谋杀案调查的继续，宫泽一家的四名成员举行了葬礼。干男的母亲节子深受创伤，无法行走，必须被人抬着进去。泰子的母亲和妹妹对他们与遇害家庭共同居住的房子产生了深深的恐惧，以至于他们完全搬离了世田谷。
family that they left set a guy all together. The situation had left Haruko with a feeling of shame and Ann was plagued by thoughts of suicide. The Tokyo Metropolitan Police Department established a special task force to focus exclusively on the murders. Given that the killer had left behind an abundance of genetic material, expectations were high that he would be promptly identified. The killer had left numerous fingerprints throughout the Miyazawa's house.
这种情况给春子留下了耻辱感，而安妮则饱受自杀念头的折磨。东京都警视厅成立了一个特别专案组，专门负责调查这起谋杀案。鉴于凶手留下了大量的基因材料，各方对能够迅速将其身份查明抱有很高的期望。凶手在宫泽家的房子里留下了无数的指纹。
His thumbprint had a distinctive swirl with two lines at the centre that was likened to a pig's nose. Police ran the prints through the Japanese criminal database but didn't find a match. They also tested them against those obtained from local residents, with no success. The unflushed feces in the toilet were compared to the stomach contents of the Miyazawa family members, all of whom had eaten the same food at their final meal. As the feces differed from the stomach contents, it was clear it belonged to the killer. His stool consisted of green beans with sesame dressing.
他的拇指印有一个独特的漩涡，中心有两条线，被比作“猪鼻子”。警察将这些指纹输入了日本犯罪数据库，但没有找到匹配项。他们还将这些指纹与当地居民的指纹进行比对，也没有成功。马桶里未冲洗的粪便与宫泽家成员的胃内容物进行了比对，所有这些人在他们最后一餐中都吃了相同的食物。由于粪便与胃内容物不同，很明显它属于凶手。他的粪便由青豆加芝麻酱组成。
As this was a popular Japanese dish that is often homemade, it didn't provide any leads. Based on his footprints at the scene, the killer had been wearing a pair of slightly worn-in slasinger-brand tennis or basketball shoes. The shoes were manufactured in South Korea between October 1998 and November 2000 and were one of 4,530 pairs made. They were the equivalent to size 27.5 in Japan or 9 in Australian sizing, which were only ever available to purchase on the South Korean market and had never been sold in Japan. The shoe was likely white, with a gray, white, or blue sole.
由于这是一道受欢迎且通常是自制的日本菜，它没有提供任何线索。根据他在现场的足迹，凶手穿着一双稍微穿旧的史莱辛格（Slazenger）品牌网球鞋或篮球鞋。这些鞋子于1998年10月至2000年11月在韩国制造，是制造的4,530双鞋之一。它们相当于日本的27.5码或澳大利亚的9码，这些鞋子仅在韩国市场出售过，从未在日本出售。这双鞋可能是白色的，鞋底是灰色、白色或蓝色。
The killer's hat was known as a crushestile hat, a name derived from the way that such hats could essentially be crushed down to any size without being damaged, making them easy to fit into backpacks or luggage. It was made of gray wool with a black band around the rim, and the label indicated it was sold after September 21, 1999. Almost 3,500 hats matching this description were sold in Japan between July 1998 and November 2000, with a retail value of around 1900 yen, or 30 Australian dollars. It was predominantly sold by retailer Marufuru Corporation, with primary sales occurring
凶手的帽子被称为卷边帽（crusher hat），这个名字源于这种帽子基本上可以被压成任何尺寸而不会损坏，这使得它们很容易塞进背包或行李中。它由灰色羊毛制成，边缘有一条黑色的带子，标签显示它是1999年9月21日之后售出的。1998年7月至2000年11月期间，日本售出了近3,500顶符合此描述的帽子，零售价约为1900日元或30澳元。它主要由丸富（Marufuru）公司零售，主要销售地区在
in the Kanto region of Japan. The killer's green-checkered scarf was 30cm wide, 130cm long, and made of low-quality acrylic fabric. It didn't have a tag or label, so police reached out to the public urging anyone who recognized it to come forward. Local people reported that they had received an identical scarf as a cheap prize or promotional item. One person had received it from a junior high school uniform retailer, another from an arcade
日本的关东地区。凶手的绿格围巾宽30厘米，长130厘米，由低质量的腈纶织物制成。它没有标签或标牌，因此警方呼吁公众，敦促任何认出它的人挺身而出。当地人报告说，他们曾将一条相同的围巾作为廉价奖品或促销品收到过。一个人从初中校服零售商那里得到了它，另一个人从街机
claw machine, and another from a petrol station. The killer's black, lightweight jacket was identified as a unicorot brand air-tech jacket, in size large. In the two months prior to the murders, a total of 82,000 jackets of this type were sold nationwide in Japan, with just over 10,000 sales in Tokyo alone. The jackets retailed between 3900 and 5900 yen, the equivalent to between 60 and 90 Australian dollars at the time, and were sold exclusively by unicorot at their retail stores, online and via mail order.
抓娃娃机中得到了它，还有一个从加油站得到了它。凶手的黑色轻便夹克被识别为优衣库（Unicorot）品牌的Airttech夹克，尺码为大号（large）。在谋杀发生前的两个月里，日本全国总共售出了82,000件这种类型的夹克，仅在东京的销量就略多于10,000件。这些夹克的零售价在3900到5900日元之间，相当于当时60到90澳元之间，并且仅由优衣库在其零售店、线上和邮购渠道独家销售。
The jacket's pockets contained grains of sand that had originated from the Miura Peninsula coast, located south of Tokyo. There were also traces of pollen that came from either an ornamental Japanese pomegranate plant or a zelkova tree, a deciduous species belonging to the Elm family. Red leaves from either a zelkova or willow tree were also found, as were traces of bird droppings thought to have come from a sparrow. In addition, soil particles were detected and traced to the province that surrounds South Korea's capital city of Seoul.
夹克的口袋里含有源自东京以南的三浦半岛海岸的沙粒。还带有花粉痕迹，这些花粉要么来自观赏性的日本石榴植物，要么来自榉树（属于榆科的落叶树种）。还发现了来自榉树或柳树的红色叶子，以及被认为来自麻雀的鸟粪痕迹。此外，还检测到了土壤颗粒，并追溯到韩国首都首尔周围的省份。
The killer's raglan-style sweatshirt was a size large, with a pale grey body and light purple sleeves. It had been sold between August and December of 2000 by the Marufuru Corporation, the same retailer that sold the killer's crusher hat, and was priced at approximately 1900 yen, or 30 Australian dollars at the time. Only 130 raglan sweatshirts of that variety were ever sold throughout Japan. At the time of the murders, it was stocked at four stores in Tokyo, and only ten had been purchased in the city.
凶手的插肩袖运动衫是均码大号，浅灰色身子，浅紫色袖子。它是由丸富公司在2000年8月至12月期间销售的，该公司也出售了凶手的卷边帽，当时售价约为1900日元或30澳元。全日本总共只售出了130件这种款式的插肩袖运动衫。谋杀发生时，它在东京的四家商店有售，并且在全市仅售出了十件。
Police appealed for anyone who had bought the sweatshirt at one of these four stores to contact them to rule themselves out of the investigation, but they were only able to track down one owner. You may be afraid of reporting this to the police, thinking that if you have this sweatshirt or remember having bought one, you may be treated as a criminal. There is no need to worry about such a thing. The perpetrator took off his sweatshirt and left it at the crime scene. Locating the same sweatshirt now would, therefore, prove that you are not the perpetrator.
警方呼吁在其中四家店买过这件运动衫的任何人与他们联系，以便将自己排除在调查之外，但他们只追踪到了一位机主。您可能会害怕向警方报案，认为如果您有这件运动衫或记得买过一件，您可能会被当作罪犯对待。没有必要担心这种事情。凶手脱下了他的运动衫，把它留在了犯罪现场。因此，现在找到同一件运动衫将证明您不是凶手。
Locating the whereabouts of nine other sweatshirts would directly lead us to identify the perpetrator. We need your cooperation on this. The killer had also left behind a pair of adjustable Edwin brand black leather gloves size 36 cm. Given that the murders occurred in the middle of winter and the killer's fingerprints were found throughout the house, it seemed likely he had been wearing them for warmth rather than to avoid leaving prints. 10,755 pairs of these gloves had been sold between 1998 and the year 2000 at two primary
找到另外九件运动衫的下落将直接指引我们确定凶手的身份。我们需要您在这方面的合作。凶手还留下一副可调节的埃德温（Edwin）品牌黑色真皮手套，尺码为36厘米。鉴于谋杀案发生在严冬之中，而且凶手的指纹遍布全屋，他戴着手套似乎是为了保暖，而不是为了避免留下指纹。1998年至2000年间，在两家主要商店售出了10,755副这种手套。
stores. One of which was the Marufuru Corporation, where the crusher hat and raglan sweatshirt had also been purchased. Two plain black handkerchiefs belonging to the killer appeared to have been recently washed and ironed. Over the previous five years, a total of 66,500 matching handkerchiefs had been manufactured and sold by Japanese retail company Muji, which sells a variety of household and consumer goods.
其中一家是丸富公司，卷边帽和插肩袖运动衫也是在那里购买的。属于凶手的两块素黑手帕看起来像是最近刚洗过并熨烫过。在过去的五年里，日本零售公司无印良品（Muji）总共制造和售出了66,500块匹配的手帕，该公司销售各种家庭和消费品。
One of the handkerchiefs left at the crime scene had been folded into a triangular shape and had squeezed edges as though the killer wore it as a face mask. The other was unfolded and had a 3 cm hole cut near its centre. Police suspected this one was used by the killer as a makeshift pouch for his knife to protect himself against injury. This method was known to be used by employees at fish processing facilities to protect themselves and allow for a firmer grip when cleaning, scaling and filleting fish. Finally, there was the black and grey hip bag left behind by the killer, known as a
留在犯罪现场的手帕之一被折叠成三角形，边缘有挤压过的痕迹，就好像凶手把它当作口罩戴过一样。另一块没有折叠，中心附近被剪了一个3厘米的洞。警察怀疑凶手用这块手帕做了一个临时的刀鞘，以保护自己免受伤害。众所周知，这种方法被鱼类加工厂的员工所使用，以保护自己并在清洁、去鳞和片鱼时提供更牢固的抓地力。最后，是凶手留下的黑灰色腰包，
bum bag in Australia or fanny pack in the United States. It was 21 cm wide, 23.5 cm high and 9.5 cm deep, which equated to the approximate size of a B5 notebook. The belt secured to the bag was 83 cm long but had been adjusted to fit a waist measuring between 70 and 75 cm. The bag was old and worn and also came with a shoulder strap so it could be used as a pouchel. It was manufactured in Osaka between 1995 and 1999 with 2,850 sold at discount stores
在澳大利亚被称为腰包（bum bag），在美国被称为腰包（fanny pack）。它宽21厘米，高23.5厘米，深9.5厘米，大约相当于B5笔记本的大小。固定在包上的带子长83厘米，但经过调整以适合腰围在70到75厘米之间的人。这个包又旧又破，还配有一根肩带，因此可以当做单肩包使用。它于1995年至1999年在大阪制造，全日本的折扣店售出了2,850个。
throughout Japan. Two strands of black hair believed to belong to the killer were found in the bag. They had been intentionally cut rather than having fallen out naturally, with one measuring 2.5 cm and the other 1.5 mm. Also inside were stains from a fluorescent red dye that illuminated when highlighted with a UV light. Police had found a similar fluorescent agent inside the Miyazawa family's garage, yet the garage was locked on the night of the murders with no indication that the killer
包里发现了两根被认为是凶手的黑发。它们是被刻意剪断的，而不是自然脱落的，一根长2.5厘米，另一根长1.5毫米。里面还有荧光红染料的污渍，用紫外线照射时会发光。警察在宫泽一家的车库里发现了类似的荧光剂，然而车库在谋杀当晚是锁着的，没有迹象表明凶手
had gone inside. This raised the possibility that the killer had been to the house on a previous occasion. Yet the dyes were determined to be unrelated, with the dye inside the bag identified as having come from a popular highlighter pen that could be purchased at most station restores. Like the killer's jacket pockets, the hip bag also contained granules of sand. Some of these contained quartz, with a similar composition to desert sand found near the city of Las Vegas in the United States. Several also contained radioactive monazite, believed to originate from the US state of
进去过。这引发了一种可能性，即凶手曾于此前去过这所房子。然而，经确定这些染料并无关联，包里的染料被认定来自一种可以在大多数文具店买到的流行荧光笔。像凶手的夹克口袋一样，腰包也含有细小的沙粒。其中一些含有石英，其成分类似于在美国拉斯维加斯市附近发现的沙漠沙。几个还含有放射性独居石，据信源自美国
California, including near the Edwards Air Force Base in the southwestern Mojave Desert. Other grains were traced to Japan's Miura Peninsula, similar to the sand found in the jacket. Further remnants found in the hip bag were analyzed to reveal tiny glass spheres of barium titanate powder, which is used by skateboarders as a form of grip tape to prevent their feet from slipping off the board. Oils and compounds that had come from a perfume or aftershave were lifted from both the hip bag and handkerchiefs.
加利福尼亚州，包括西南部莫哈韦沙漠中的爱德华兹空军基地附近。其他沙粒被追溯到日本的三浦半岛，类似于夹克上发现的沙。在腰包中发现的进一步残留物经过分析，显现出微小的钛酸钡粉末玻璃球，滑板爱好者将其用作一种防滑带，以防止他们的脚从滑板上滑落。从腰包和手帕中都提取出了来自香水或须后水的油脂和化合物。
By compiling the specific combination of elements, forensic experts were able to determine that the killer had at one point been wearing draka noir. The moderately priced order toilette fragrance was manufactured by French fashion brand Guy LaRouche and had been sold in Japan since 1982. Based on the clothing and forensic evidence obtained from the crime scene, the perpetrator was likely between 15 and 35 years of age, around 170cm tall, of slim build with black or blackish brown hair, and was right-handed. He also had to be agile enough to have exited the house via the bathroom window.
通过汇编这些特定的元素组合，法医专家得以确定凶手曾一度使用过“龙虎之穴”（Drakkar Noir）古龙水。这款中等价位的男士淡香水由法国时尚品牌盖·拉罗什（Guy Laroche）制造，自1982年起开始在日本销售。根据从犯罪现场获得的衣物和法医证据，作案者年龄可能在15至35岁之间，身高约170厘米，身材苗条，留着黑色或黑褐色头发，是右撇子。他的身手也必须足够敏捷，才能通过浴室窗户离开房子。
Police believed he either lived alone or with family who wouldn't be suspicious if he was out late at night. It was also possible that he struggled with money and that the crime was financially motivated. Based on several factors, including the traces of grip tape found in the hip bag, the police theorized that the killer could have been part of the group of skateboarders that Mikio confronted in the week leading up to his death. Both California and the Miura Peninsula had a lively skateboarding subculture and a draka noir cologne had been popular with professional skateboarders throughout the 1980s.
警方认为，他要么独居，要么与家人同住，深夜外出也不会引起怀疑。还有一种可能是他经济拮据，这起犯罪具有经济动机。根据多项因素，包括腰包中发现的防滑胶带痕迹，警方推测凶手可能是干雄在生前最后一周与之对峙的一群滑板爱好者之一。加利福尼亚州和三浦半岛都有着活跃的滑板亚文化，而一款名为“德拉卡黑” (draka noir) 的古龙水在整个20世纪80年代的专业滑板手中间非常流行。
At the time of the murders, raglan shirts and hip bags were also commonly worn by skateboarders. Due to the vast amount of physical and forensic evidence available, it was expected that the suspect would be promptly identified, but weeks passed without any major breakthroughs. Neighbors and associates of Mikio and Yasuko were questioned as to whether they had recently traveled to both California and the Miura Peninsula, but none had. On Monday, April 9, 2001, three months after the murders, a stone Oji Zosan statue was found on the side of the road that ran alongside the Sankawa River, west of the Miyazawa family home. This type of statue is known to represent Jizo Bodhisattva, a Buddhist enlightened being
在凶杀案发生时，插肩袖衬衫和腰包也是滑板爱好者的常见装扮。由于有大量的物证和法医证据，人们曾预计嫌疑人会很快被确认，但几周过去了，并没有取得任何重大突破。干雄和泰子的邻居及熟人被盘问是否最近去过加利福尼亚和三浦半岛，但都没有。2001年4月9日星期一，即凶杀案发生三个月后，在宫泽家住宅以西、三川河旁的道路边发现了一尊石质王子藏山雕像。这种类型的雕像被称为地藏菩萨，是佛教觉悟者
regarded as the guardian of unborn, aborted or stillborn babies and of children who die prematurely. The statue was made of heavy white granite and depicted a child monk praying on a pedestal. It was 59 centimeters tall and weighed 19.5 kilograms. On the bottom of the pedestal was an inscription resembling the Chinese character for the number 6. Investigators believed the statue was significant and that it had been left by the river on either the evening of April 8 or the morning of April 9. They were unsure whether it had been placed at that location by someone with good intentions or if the killer or someone close to him was responsible. Forensic examination of the statue uncovered nothing of significance.
被视为未出生、流产或死产的婴儿以及夭折儿童的守护神。这座雕像是用重质白色花岗岩制成的，描绘了一个在底座上祈祷的儿童僧侣。它高59厘米，重19.5公斤。底座底部有一个类似于汉字数字“6”的刻印。调查人员认为这座雕像意义重大，它是4月8日晚上或4月9日上午被遗弃在河边的。他们不确定将其放置在该处的人是出于好意，还是凶手或与其亲近的人所为。对该雕像的法医检验没有发现任何重大线索。
Police distributed 30,000 posters of the statue, appealing for anyone with knowledge about it to come forward and made an additional request for information about the inscription on the bottom. Despite these efforts, no definite link was drawn between the statue and the crimes. By June 2001, six months had passed since the murders and 150 police officers continued to work exclusively on the case. During that time, a total of 21,000 officers had been involved in some form or another and had covered 2,700 potential leads, but the killer was no closer to being identified. The case languished for years despite the amount of time and resources dedicated to solving it and the murderer remained unknown along with his true motive.
警方分发了3万张该雕像的海报，呼吁任何知情者站出来提供线索，并进一步要求提供有关底部铭文的信息。尽管做出了这些努力，但该雕像与罪行之间并没有确凿的联系。到2001年6月，谋杀案发生已经六个月了，仍有150名警察继续全力侦办此案。在此期间，共有2万1千名警察以这样或那样的方式参与其中，排查了2700条潜在线索，但离锁定凶手仍无进展。尽管投入了大量时间和资源来破案，但该案多年来一直停滞不前，凶手及其真正动机依然是个谜。
In 2003, family, friends and supporters of the Slain family hosted a photography exhibition featuring images of the Mayor's Hours that were returned from police earlier that year. Among the collection was a photo of Nina cuddling her newborn baby brother, Rayi, and another of the family gathered happily around a birthday cake to celebrate Rayi's second birthday. One of the exhibition's organisers said, We want people not to just think about how heinous the crime was, but also how happy the family was in life. Given that the killer's sneakers were sold exclusively in South Korea and the soil particles from his jacket pocket were also traced back to the same country, Japanese investigators
2003年，遇害家庭的家人、朋友和支持者举办了一场摄影展，展出了当年早些时候从警方那里归还的市长之家的照片。在这些藏品中，有一张妮娜抱着她刚出生不久的弟弟雷伊的照片，还有一张全家人为了庆祝雷伊两岁生日而幸福地聚在生日蛋糕周围的照片。其中一位展览组织者说：“我们希望人们不仅要思考这起罪行有多么残忍，还要想想这个家庭生前是多么幸福。”鉴于凶手的运动鞋仅在韩国销售，且其夹克口袋里的土壤颗粒也可追溯到同一个国家，日本调查人员
requested that South Korean authorities run the killer's fingerprints through their own national database. They agreed, but no matches were made. In 2006, advanced DNA testing allowed forensic experts to determine the killer's racial profile through anthropological analysis of the bloodstained sweatshirt found at the scene. The DNA didn't match any of the profiles in the Japanese police database, but an ancestral analysis did reveal that the killer's father had a 1 in 13 chance of being Japanese, a 1 in 10 chance of being Chinese, and a 1 in 3 chance of being Korean. The killer's mitochondrial DNA sequence revealed the ancestry on his mother's side
请求韩国当局将凶手的指纹录入他们自己的国家数据库。他们同意了，但没有匹配成功。2006年，先进的DNA检测使法医专家能够通过对现场发现的血迹运动衫进行人类学分析来确定凶手的种族特征。DNA与日本警察数据库中的任何资料都不匹配，但祖源分析确实显示，凶手父亲是日本人的几率为13分之一，是中国人的几率为10分之一，是韩国人的几率为3分之一。凶手的线粒体DNA序列显示，他母亲那边的祖先
was Adriatic and Mediterranean South European. As the majority of interracial marriages between Japanese and European individuals had only occurred within the past couple of generations, experts believed that the killer was more likely to be continental Asian than Japanese, or that the interracial conception had only occurred in his mother or grandmother's generation. By December 2006, six years after the murder, a total of 140,000 police officers had been involved in the investigation in some capacity. 98 individuals were still under investigation, with police focusing on people who may have been financially motivated to commit the crime, as well as those who may have held a grudge against a member of the family.
是亚得里亚海和地中海南部欧洲人。由于日本和欧洲个人之间的跨种族婚姻大多只发生在过去的两代人中，专家认为凶手更有可能是大陆亚洲人而不是日本人，或者这种跨种族繁衍只发生在母亲或祖母这一代。截至2006年12月，即谋杀案发生六年之后，总共有14万名警察以各种身份参与了调查。仍有98人处于调查之中，警方重点关注那些可能出于经济动机犯罪的人，以及可能对家庭成员怀恨在心的人。
One former investigator was convinced that the killer had a particular interest in eight-year-old Nina Miyazawa, as highlighted by the extent of her injuries. It was reported that a young man who frequented the locations where Nina attended ballet and piano lessons had been known to watch her intently and keep track of her movements. Additionally, his genetic ancestry fit the killer's DNA profile, as he had a Japanese father and southern European mother. The former investigator interviewed the suspect and went as far as searching his home and collecting his fingerprints, but the prints didn't match the killers. Also in 2006, freelance journalist Toro Saito published a book titled The Setagaya Family Murder Case, Confessions of Intruders,
前调查员确信，凶手对8岁的妮娜·宫泽有着特殊的兴趣，这从她受伤的程度可以看出。据报道，一名经常出现在妮娜上芭蕾舞和钢琴课地点的年轻男子，曾被发现一直在密切注视她并跟踪她的行踪。此外，他的遗传祖源符合凶手的DNA特征，因为他有一个日本父亲和南欧母亲。前调查员对这名嫌疑人进行了讯问，甚至搜查了他的家并采集了他的指纹，但指纹与凶手不符。同样在2006年，自由记者斋藤彻出版了一本名为《世田谷一家杀人事件：闯入者的自白》的书，
claiming she had uncovered the truth about the Miyazawa family murders and the identity of the killer. The book attracted severe criticism from the media and investigators, as it was filled with glaring inconsistencies, including falsified quotes from family members. In response to the book, police chief Takeshi Tsuchida stated, The contents are fundamentally different from the facts in general. From the intrusion to the killing method, the criminals own medical treatment, personal computer operation, escape method, victim's behavior, belongings, fingerprints, etc. Everything is different from the fact. There is a concern that it will have an adverse effect. In December 2007, Yasuko Miyazawa's sister, Anne Irie, published her own book about the murders,
声称她已经揭开了宫泽一家谋杀案的真相以及凶手的身份。该书遭到了媒体和调查人员的严厉批评，因为它充满了明显的矛盾，包括伪造的家庭成员引言。针对这本书，警察局长土田猛表示：“内容与一般事实根本不从。从侵入到杀害手段、罪犯自身的医疗处理、个人电脑操作、逃跑手段、受害者的行为、随身物品、指纹等，一切都与事实不符。人们担心这会产生负面影响。”2007年12月，宫泽泰子的姐姐入江杏出版了她自己关于这起谋杀案的书，
titled If You Can Understand The Meaning Of This Sadness, The Setagaya Case, The Story of Loss and Rebirth. That same month, Japan's National Police Agency announced that a reward of 3 million yen, the equivalent of 30,000 Australian dollars at the time, was available for information regarding the Miyazawa family case. In the following year, it was reported that Japanese police had asked authorities in China, the United States, and some Western countries to provide fingerprint records to compare against their suspect. But it is unclear what progress, if any, was made. At the time the murders were committed, Japan had a 15-year statute of limitations on murder charges,
书名为《如果你能理解这种悲伤的含义：世田谷案件，失去与重生的故事》。同月，日本警察厅宣布，提供有关宫泽家族案件线索的悬赏金为300万日元，相当于当时的3万澳元。第二年，据报道日本警察已要求中国、美国和一些西方国家的当局提供指纹记录，以便与他们的嫌疑人进行比对。但目前还不清楚取得了什么进展（如果有的话）。在谋杀案发生时，日本对谋杀罪有15年的诉讼时效，
due to the belief that evidence could be lost or dissipate over time, that witnesses' memories can fade, and the demands for harsh penalties can wane as the feelings of surviving loved ones diminish. In 2009, the statute of limitations was increased from 15 to 25 years, but because the Miyazawa family murders occurred before that time, the new limitations did not apply to their case. This meant that if their killer was not caught by 2015, he could not be prosecuted for the murders. In February of 2009, Mikio's 80-year-old brother Yoshiyuki Miyazawa and Yasuko's sister Ann Iriea, together with a group of 15 other families whose loved ones were victims of unsolved murders, established an association called the Sora No Kai, to help support others in their situation.
这是因为人们认为证据可能会随着时间的推移而丢失或消散，目击者的记忆可能会褪色，随着幸存亲属情感的减弱，对严厉惩罚的要求也会减弱。2009年，诉讼时效从15年延长至25年，但由于宫泽一家的谋杀案发生在此之前，新的时效不适用于他们的案件。这意味着，如果凶手在2015年之前没有被抓获，他将无法因谋杀罪而被起诉。2009年2月，干雄80岁的哥哥宫泽良行和泰子的姐姐入江杏，与另外15个遭遇未破谋杀案的受害者家属一起，成立了一个名为“空之会”的协会，旨在帮助支持处境相似的其他人。
Loosely translated, Sora No Kai was a victim of the murder, Sora No Kai means infinite time, alluding to the ongoing grief and uncertainty that bereaved family members were forced to endure. The purpose of the Sora No Kai was to persuade the Japanese government to abolish the statute of limitations on murder altogether, with a statement on the group's website reading, The feelings of our bereaved have never faded in 15 or 25 years. The organization also highlighted that modern improvements in forensic and investigative technology, including advanced DNA testing, meant that evidence didn't
“空之会”大致翻译过来就是谋杀案受害者，“空之会”意味着无限的时间，暗示着死者家属被迫忍受的持续悲伤和不确定性。“空之会”的宗旨是说服日本政府彻底废除谋杀罪的诉讼时效，该组织网站上的声明写道：“我们遗属的感受在15年或25年里从未消退过。”该组织还强调，现代法医学和调查技术的改进，包括先进的DNA检测，意味着证据并不
necessarily dissipate over time, and that it had become easier to prove cases in court even after many years had passed. Also supporting the end to the statute of limitations was a group called the National Crime Victims Association, and public support for the cause began to increase. On June 12th, the Sora No Kai gave the Minister of Justice a petition containing 45,000 signatures, with the number soon growing to over 78,000. Their efforts paid off, and in April 2010, Japan abolished the statute of limitations on murder with immediate effect, including, for all existing unsolved cases, where the statute of limitations had not yet expired. Two and a half years later, on September 6th, 2012,
一定会随着时间的推移而消散，而且即使过了很多年，在法庭上证明案件也变得更容易了。支持废除诉讼时效的还有一个名为“全国犯罪受害者协会”的组织，公众对这一诉求的支持也开始增加。“空之会”于6月12日向法务大臣递交了一份包含45,000个签名的请愿书，随后这一数字很快增长到78,000多。他们的努力有了回报，2010年4月，日本立即废除了谋杀罪的诉讼时效，包括所有尚未过诉讼时效的现有未破案件。两年半后的2012年9月6日，
Mikio's 84-year-old father, Yoshiyuki, passed away in hospital after months spent battling pneumonia. Up until his death, Yoshiyuki worked tirelessly to find answers to the questions surrounding the murder of his son's family. Prior to his death, he commented, The culprit may not be arrested while I'm alive, but why did four people have to be killed? I really want to ask the culprit for the real reason, the truth. Former police chief Takeshi Tsuchida, who helped establish the Sora No Kai with Yoshiyuki, told reporters he was remorseful that the case remained unresolved, and expressed his desire for progress. In late December 2014, the reward for information was increased to 20 million yen,
干雄84岁的父亲良行在经历了几个月与肺炎的搏斗后在医院去世。直到去世前，良行一直在不知疲倦地寻找围绕他儿子一族被杀案的种种疑问的答案。在去世前，他评论道：“在我活着的时候，罪犯可能不会被捕，但为什么非要杀死四个人呢？我真的很想问罪犯真正的理由、真相。”前警察局长土田猛曾与良行共同创立“空之会”，他告诉记者，他对案件仍未解决感到遗憾，并表达了希望取得进展的愿望。2014年12月下旬，线索悬赏金增加到2000万日元，
the equivalent to around $207,000 Australian dollars at the time. That same month, Japanese television network Asahi aired a program about the Miyazawa family murders in which a reporter and former member of the FBI used criminal behavioural profiling to uncover clues as to the killer's identity. They deduced that the person responsible was an acquaintance who held a grudge against the family, and implied that Yasuko's sister, Anne, supported their opinion. After the program aired, Anne claimed the show used various production and editing methods to create the illusion that she agreed with their conclusion, when she did not. She lodged a formal complaint to Japan's broadcasting ethics and program
相当于当时的约20.7万澳元。同月，日本朝日电视台播出了一个关于宫泽一家谋杀案的节目，节目中一名记者和前联邦调查局成员利用犯罪行为侧写来寻找有关凶手身份的线索。他们推断，责任人是一个对这个家庭怀恨在心的熟人，并暗示泰子的姐姐入江杏支持他们的观点。节目播出后，入江杏声称该节目使用了各种制作和剪辑手法，制造了她同意他们结论的错觉，但事实并非如此。她向日本放送伦理与节目
improvement organisation, known as the BPO, alleging that the program misrepresented her. In a subsequent press conference, Anne said, I felt that what I had built was destroyed by this program. It is regrettable as I have accepted every kind of media interview, hoping it will lead to the case being solved. The Asahi network declined Anne's request for an apology, stating that it was simply a difference in opinions. The BPO determined that while the TV program did not damage the social reputation of Anne or the bereaved family or violate their human rights, the content lacked fairness and proper consideration of broadcasting ethics. Anne was pleased that the committee
改进机构（简称BPO）正式投诉，指控该节目歪曲了她的立场。在随后的新闻发布会上，入江杏说：“我感觉我所建立的一切都被这个节目摧毁了。这令人遗憾，因为我接受了各种各样的媒体采访，希望这能促成案件的解决。”朝日电视台拒绝了入江杏的道歉要求，称这纯粹是意见分歧。BPO裁定，虽然该电视节目没有损害入江杏或死者家属的社会声誉或侵犯他们的基本人权，但其内容缺乏公平性，且对广播伦理缺乏适当的考虑。入江杏对委员会
legitimised her concerns, and the Asahi network agreed they would take the BPO's feedback into consideration in the future. From the onset of the investigation, Mikio's computer records had led the police to believe that the killer had remained inside the family's home until around 10 o'clock the morning after the murders. However, in early 2015, it was announced that the 10am computer activity had likely been triggered by the device's mouse falling onto the floor, rather than someone actively accessing it. Yasuko's mother, Haruko, who discovered the bodies, agreed that it was possible she could have knocked the mouse off Mikio's desk when she moved through the house, although she couldn't remember whether or not this had happened.
正视了她的关切感到高兴，朝日电视台也同意在未来将BPO的反馈考虑在内。从调查一开始，干雄的电脑记录就让警方相信，凶手在谋杀案发生后一直留在该家庭的住宅内，直到第二天早上10点左右。然而，2015年初，有消息称，上午10点的电脑活动很可能是由于设备的鼠标掉在地板上触发的，而不是有人在积极操作它。发现尸体的泰子的母亲春子承认，当她在屋里走动时，她有可能把鼠标从干雄的桌子上碰掉了，尽管她记不清这是否真的发生过。
It is unclear whether police knew this information earlier on and chose to withhold it from the public, but regardless, it meant that any potential sightings or suspicious movement in the neighbourhood during the earlier hours of that morning gained significance. To mark the 15th anniversary of the murders, on December 30, 2015, investigators gathered out the front of the Miyazawa's home to lay flowers and hold a silent prayer. By this point, almost 250,000 law enforcement officers had worked on the case, and police had received a total of 12,545 pieces of information relating to it. Leads continued to come in, with 324 new pieces of information gathered in 2015 alone, and investigators renewed their vow to find the killer.
目前尚不清楚警方是否更早了解这一信息并选择向公众隐瞒，但无论如何，这意味着当天清晨邻里中任何潜在的目击事件或可疑移动都变得意义重大。为了纪念谋杀案发生15周年，2015年12月30日，调查人员聚集在宫泽家门前献花并进行默哀。到此时，已有近25万名执法人员参与了该案的调查，警方总共收到了12,545条与该案相关的线索。线索源源不断地涌入，仅2015年就收集到了324条新线索，调查人员重申了找到凶手的决心。
To coincide with the anniversary, one of Japan's most famous investigative journalists, using the pen name Fumia Ichihashi, released a book titled, The Setagaya Family Murder Case, 15 Years On, The New Facts. Ichihashi spent several years researching the book, during which he concluded that the killer was a former South Korean soldier, turned killer for hire, identified by the pseudonym Lee Inan. Inan was recruited into the South Korean military at a young age, and was bullied by his superiors, which caused the shift in his behaviour. He was trained in self-defense and taekwondo, and had been undertaking combat and shooting training at a mercenary school, when he met a Japanese man identified as Mr Kanada.
为了配合这一周年纪念，日本最著名的调查记者之一化名“市桥文哉”，出版了一本名为《世田谷一家杀人事件：15年后的新事实》的书。市桥花了好几年时间为这本书进行研究，在此期间他得出结论，凶手是一名曾转行为杀手的韩国前士兵，化名为李仁安。仁安年轻时被征入韩国军队，并遭到上司的霸凌，这导致了他的行为发生转变。他接受过自卫和跆拳道训练，并且在一家雇佣兵学校进行过搏击和射击训练，在那里他遇到了一名被称为金田先生的日本人。
According to Ichihashi, Mr Kanada was the former head of a religious group in Tokyo, who used the mercenary school to recruit young men into his criminal organisation. Kanada had lost a large amount of money due to failed businesses, and began working with the dodgy real estate brokers who specialised in buying homes at discounted rates, and then selling the land to developers for elevated profits. These brokers had reached out to the Miyazawa's, requesting they sell their home to them, instead of receiving the compensation money they borrowed from the government as a result of losing their house to the expansion of Soshigaya Park. The Miyazawa's had refused, prompting Mr Kanada
根据市桥的说法，金田先生是东京一个宗教团体的头目，他利用雇佣兵学校招募年轻人加入他的犯罪组织。金田因为投资失败损失了大量金钱，并开始与那些专门以折扣价买下房屋，然后将土地以高价卖给开发商以获取暴利的无良房地产经纪人合作。这些经纪人曾接触过宫泽一家，要求他们将房子卖给他们，而不是接受他们因房子失去以扩建祖师谷公园而从政府那里借来的补偿金。宫泽一家拒绝了，这促使金田先生
to hire Lee Inan to intimidate them into accepting the deal. To gain access to the family, Inan allegedly posed as an associate of Mr Kanada's who could provide learning and speech therapy support to six-year-old Rei Miyazawa. He then exceeded his orders by brutally murdering the whole family and attempting to steal their compensation money. In his book, Ichihashi claimed that in 2003 he secretly collected Lee Inan's fingerprints and unofficially compared them to the prints identified at the Miyazawa crime scene, revealing a match. Flight departure and immigration records also showed that the day after the murders, Inan flew to Taiwan from Haneda Airport, located 20km southeast of the Miyazawa's house. He had also
雇佣李仁安恐吓他们接受这笔交易。为了进入这个家庭，仁安据称伪装成金田先生的一个合伙人，可以为6岁的宫泽礼提供学习和语言治疗支持。随后他越权行事，残忍地谋杀了全家，并试图偷走他们的补偿金。市桥在书中声称，他在2003年秘密收集了李仁安的指纹，并将其与在宫泽犯罪现场发现的指纹进行非官方比对，结果显示相吻合。航班离港和出入境记录还显示，谋杀案发生的第二天，仁安从位于宫泽家东南20公里的羽田机场飞往台湾。他还
previously travelled to California, which could account for the sand found in the killer's clothing. After the murders, Inan and Mr Kanada allegedly had a falling out, and Inan began working as an assassin in South Korea and the United States, before eventually working in armed groups in the Philippines and then acting as a free assassin. In response to Ichihashi's claims, former police chief Takeshi Tsuchida said, It's 100% nonsense. If the book was true, the criminal would have been caught. It's okay if it was a fictional novel, but I have strong doubts calling it non-fiction. In his book, Ichihashi criticized the media for drip-feeding information to the public over the years, rather than releasing new details as they came to light, which he believed made it
曾去过加利福尼亚，这可以解释凶手衣服上发现的沙子。谋杀案发生后，仁安和金田先生据称闹翻了，仁安开始在韩国和美国担任杀手，后来在菲律宾的武装团体中工作，最后成为一名自由杀手。针对市桥的说法，前警察局长土田猛表示：“这纯属胡说八道。如果这本书是真的，罪犯早就被抓到了。如果这是一部虚构小说倒也罢了，但我对它被称为纪实作品抱有强烈的怀疑。”市桥在书中批评媒体多年来一直向公众挤牙膏式地透露信息，而不是在掌握新细节时立即公布，他认为这使得
even more difficult for the truth to be exposed. He also severely critiqued the police handling of the case, saying they made several assumptions early on that hindered the investigation. He claimed the number of fingerprints and forensic evidence at the scene led to complacency, as the police assumed the killer would be quickly identified. Moreover, the brutality of the crimes had led them to assume the killer must have been suffering from a mental illness or personality disorder. Consequently, they had focused on patients who had been recently discharged from psychiatric hospitals, which Ichihashi believed was a red herring. Ichihashi thought that the police focused on one possibility at a time before moving on to
真相大白变得更加困难。他还严厉批评了警方对案件的处理方式，称他们在早期做出了几个阻碍调查的假设。他声称现场大量的指纹和法医证据导致了自满，因为警方认为凶手很快就会被查明。此外，罪行的残暴性让他们认为凶手一定患有精神疾病或人格障碍。因此，他们把重点放在了最近从精神病院出院的病人身上，市桥认为这是一个红鲱鱼（干扰视线的信息）。市桥认为，警方是一次只关注一种可能性，然后才转向
the next, rather than conducting a wide-scale investigation that examined a range of possibilities simultaneously. For example, Ichihashi believed that because the killer had eaten a typical Japanese dish before committing the murders and was able to read kanji, police had tunneled vision about his nationality and failed to consider that he may not be Japanese. Following the publication of his book, Ichihashi gave an interview to online newspaper Japan Today, in which he stated, unless there's a miracle and the criminal surrenders himself or his fingerprints match to another crime, I believe there is no chance he will be arrested. As of December 2019, 19 years since the Miyazawa family were murdered, 35 members of Tokyo's
下一种可能性，而不是进行一项能够同时检查多种可能性的广泛调查。例如，市桥认为，由于凶手在犯罪前吃了一道典型的日本菜并且能够阅读汉字，警方对他的国籍产生了思维定势，未能考虑到他可能不是日本人。在出版了他的书之后，市桥接受了在线报纸《日本时报》的采访，他在采访中表示：“除非发生奇迹，罪犯自首或者他的指纹与另一桩罪行相匹配，否则我认为他被捕的机会为零。”截至2019年12月，即宫泽一家被谋杀19年之际，东京
Metropolitan Police Force were still assigned exclusively to the case. Of the 130 raglan sweatshirts sold throughout Japan that matched the one belonging to the killer, police have only been able to track down and rule out 12 owners. The case remains one of Japan's longest-running and most mysterious unsolved crimes, with the streets of Setagaya still featuring signs appealing for information. The 20 million yen reward money is still available, making it the highest cash reward ever offered in Japan. Although former police chief Takeshi Tsuchida retired in 2008, he still works on the case in an unofficial capacity. On the 19th anniversary of the crimes, he told Australian news broadcaster,
大都会警察局仍有35名成员专职负责此案。在日本全国售出的130件与凶手穿的款式相符的插肩袖运动衫中，警方只追踪并排除了12名所有者。该案仍然是日本历时最长、最神秘的未破犯罪之一，世田谷的街道上仍然挂着呼吁提供线索的标语。2000万日元的悬赏金仍然有效，使其成为日本历史上提供的最高现金悬赏。尽管前警察局长土田猛已于2008年退休，但他仍以非官方身份致力于该案。在案发19周年之际，他告诉澳大利亚新闻广播公司
the ABC, when I think about the feelings of the victim's families who lost their loved ones all of a sudden, I just couldn't pass on this case to my successors. After working as an officer for 41 years, when I think about the brutality in the way he murdered the four, I just wonder, how could a sane person carry out such an extreme crime? Tsuchida said he remained in close contact with Mikio's mother, Setsuko, paying her regular visits, preparing her meals, and praying at the shrine. The Miyazawa investigation now sits in the hands of Superintendent Manabu Iidae, who remains confident that the killer will be caught. Superintendent Iidae stated,
ABC：“每当我想到那些突然失去亲人的受害者家属的心情，我就无法将这个案子交接给我的继任者。”作为一名警察工作了41年后，每当我想到他残忍杀害这四人的手段，我就会想，一个正常人怎么能做出如此极端的罪行呢？土田说，他与干雄的母亲节子保持着紧密的联系，经常去看望她，为她准备饭菜，并在神龛前祈祷。宫泽案的调查现在落在了饭田学总监手中，他依然坚信凶手会被抓获。饭田总监表示：
It is our mission to arrest the criminal who murdered four innocent people, including two young children, and make him atone for his crime. It's an atrocious case rarely seen in Japan's criminal history, and we think solving this case will help prevent similar crimes happening in the future. The former home of the Miyazawa family remains standing on land that now belongs to the Tokyo Metropolitan Government. Since the murder of the Miyazawa family, the Miyazawa family now belongs to the Tokyo Metropolitan Government. Since the murders, the house has been subject to a preservation order. But on December 26, 2019, the police issued a demolition notice
“我们的使命是逮捕谋杀四名无辜者（其中包括两名幼儿）的罪犯，并让他为自己的罪行赎罪。这是日本犯罪史上罕见的暴行，我们认为解决这起案件将有助于防止未来发生类似罪行。”宫泽一家的旧宅依然矗立在现属于东京都政府的土地上。自宫泽一家遇害以来，这座房子一直受到保护令的管束。但2019年12月26日，警方发出了拆除通知，
as the house is at risk of collapsing. Investigators stated their belief that all possible evidence has been preserved, and there would be no impact on the case if the house was demolished. Yasuko's sister, Anne, disagreed, and filed a submission for police to withdraw their notice of demolition. She told reporters for Japanese daily newspaper the Asahi Shimbun. There definitely are things that can be felt only at the crime scene. I would like people to get a sense of how the Miyazawa family lived their lives. That sense could lead to a break in the case. To gain support, Anne decided to open the house to the public. The family's belongings remained stacked inside cardboard boxes, leaving little room to move around the small house.
因为该房子有倒塌的危险。调查人员表示，他们相信所有可能的证据都已经得到保存，拆除房屋不会对案件产生影响。泰子的姐姐入江杏对此表示异议，并提交了一份申请，要求警方撤回拆除通知。她告诉日本《朝日新闻》的记者：“绝对有些东西是只有在犯罪现场才能感受到的。我希望人们能体会到宫泽一家是如何生活的。这种感觉可能会带来案件的突破。”为了获得支持，入江杏决定向公众开放这座房子。家里的物品仍然堆在纸箱里，在这个小房子里几乎没有转身的余地。
Nina and Reiya's height measurements were still marked on the living room wall. The last of which was recorded in August of 2000. Anne told reporters that the size of the home meant there was very little room for the family to flee from the perpetrator, which she believes would have only added to their terror. Quote, The family lived humbly and worked hard. It is heart-wrenching to be in this house. I am still deeply sorry that I could not save them. Roughly a year after the murders, Anne channeled her grief into something positive by creating a picture book titled, The Story of Mishuka the Bear Always Connected.
客厅的墙上仍然标记着妮娜和雷亚的身高。最后一次记录是在2000年8月。入江杏告诉记者，房子的面积意味着这个家庭几乎没有空间从行凶者手中逃脱，她认为这只会增加他们的恐怖感。引用原话：“这个家庭过着简朴的生活，工作非常努力。待在这所房子里让人心如刀割。我至今仍深深地感到遗憾，因为我没能救他们。”谋杀案发生大约一年后，入江杏将她的悲伤转化为积极的动力，创作了一本名为《永远相连的小熊米舒卡的故事》的绘本。
Using her book, she began running support seminars across Japan for grieving families who were dealing with the loss of a loved one due to crime. Anne said that she had changed from being someone who needed help from others into one who assisted those grieving through their pain. She eventually became a member of the Setagaya Ward Grief Support Study Committee and a part-time lecturer at the Sophia University Grief Research Institute. Mikio's mother, Setsuko, still keeps a shrine to Mikio Yasuko, Nina and Reiji at her home, displaying photographs of the family along with the display captain full of Nina and Reiji's toys. She prays for the family often and hopes that the killer will one day be brought to justice.
利用她的书，她开始在日本各地为因犯罪而失去亲人的悲伤家庭举办支持研讨会。入江杏说，她已经从一个需要别人帮助的人变成了一个帮助那些因痛苦而悲伤的人。她最终成为了世田谷区悲伤支持研究委员会的成员和上智大学悲伤研究所的兼职讲师。干雄的母亲节子家里仍然供奉着干雄、泰子、妮娜和雷司的神龛，上面陈列着该家庭的照片，以及摆满了妮娜和雷司玩具的陈列柜。她经常为这个家庭祈祷，并希望凶手有一天能被绳之以法。
In an interview with the ABC in December of 2019, Setsuko said she was deeply saddened by the fact that her husband had passed away before the case was solved. Commenting, That troubled us the most. Now that he's gone, I feel I have to do the hard work myself. Reflecting on the murders she lamented. I always wonder how the children would have grown up. My biggest regret is that I never got to see them grow up. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在2019年12月接受ABC采访时，节子表示，对于丈夫在案件侦破前去世一事，她感到非常悲伤。她评论道：“这让我们最感到困扰。现在他走了，我觉得我必须自己来做这件难事。”回想起谋杀案，她感叹道：“我总是想孩子们会怎样长大。我最大的遗憾是我从未看到他们长大。”该剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可留下评论。